hi i'm ryan right and i'm gerry welcome
two reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and not to see GI joe
retaliation so let's hang the [ __ ] out
securities early after most of the GI
Joes are eliminated by the president's
order there are only three remaining
Joe's left to save the United States of
America against their ultimate enemy the
Cobras reason to see number one Dwayne
Johnson you know what the rock is cool
in this [ __ ] movie [ __ ] I'm
calling in the rock I don't care what he
says he is the rock to me hopefully the
guy does not rip my head off after
watching this movie you're gonna want to
calm the rock cuz he is rock [ __ ]
solid he gets better every single movie
we're set up right from the start
we're all that's left he Helms this
movie perfectly he's the new leader of
the GI Joes he takes over the franchise
as the rock likes to do yeah another
thing too if you've ever wonder what the
rocks ethnicity is they answer in this
movie he's black they're all day it's
only one man could authorize a strike
like that I voted for him Wald ain't
saving itself he is gigantic but he's
also like very well-spoken a very
charismatic as some funny one-liners to
you know he's good and all those
qualities sort of work really well as a
high ranking military officer yeah
absolutely so way to go road-blocking
goes to the rock reason to see number
two channing tatum he's barely in the
movie but easily in this movie I he is
my favorite thing about this movie yeah
I wish this I really wish this was the
Channing Tatum and Dwayne Johnson
hanging out their chemistry is so good
together yeah I want them to be in a
buddy movie after this so we can see the
extended version of that sequence drive
it like you stole it as your good friend
you need new catchphrase they play off
each other very well they have some
great comedic timing some together one
whole weekend you looking after my
little girls yep as long as I can bring
this I love your kids but they live to
terrorize me and on top of that too when
they're being badass action heroes they
look really cool together just
everything about them made so much sense
in this movie that I wish that was the
center of this film yeah that one time
they get to kick ass together is really
kicking yeah way to go chanting for the
two scenes you had in this Ruby hey
those were 15 awesome minutes okay
reason is see number three snake eyes
snake eyes is the ninja of the GI Joes
he doesn't talk you don't see his face
for some reason though he is one of the
coolest people in this movie we'll just
look at I mean he just looks bad as
getting a helmet with this just one bar
of sudden glass material and just armor
that looks like muscles and swords and
stuff like he's just a badass and just
the way he moves
and like his fighting skills the
swordplay everything about it is awesome
underneath the suit is ray park you
might know him better as Darth Maul or
toad in the original x-men yes that's
right and he's the guy under the suit
and you kind of get some ideas about his
character I guess through his body
language maybe he has a heart maybe he
doesn't I believe he has a heart which
makes them much more likeable he's an
enigma breeze to see number 4 Storm
Shadow Storm Shadow is the evil
equivalent of snake eyes in this movie
normally a character like this might
annoy me or I might find dull or very
two-dimensional some like annoying cocky
kind of character but surprisingly I
really enjoyed watching the guy yeah no
I did too it's an easy character to make
tedious to watch and I felt like they
they you understand enough about him to
at least get why he's doing what he's
doing and like his first scene you know
he takes off his shirt and he's like
just all wet and you know what he's got
like these incredible abs I was drawn to
the guys physicality surprisingly I have
a totally like that guy's nipple reason
to see number 5 the action there is
action in this movie yeah there's some
yeah there's just a little bit kidding
this movie is loaded with action so much
so much let's break it down for you just
a little bit there's guns there's
explosions there's gadgets there's you
know I guess a little bit of military
type of spy crap going on there's
soldiers there's swordplay there's
ninjas there's dis ninja stars yeah sigh
all the crazy events weaponry would ever
want to see an old lady kicking ass yeah
hi hot babes kicking ass the only thing
it's missing is titties that's all this
movie needed with some tits and so
children also kicking ass yeah this is
some little kids blowing [ __ ] up you got
the rock holding this gigantic mother
[ __ ] machine is looming
Anna he takes the drive to tank this
gigantic tank deccan it's like they
didn't Bruce Willis is small garage
idols a little rough a neutral and can
game neutral it's like the combination
of a tank and a go-kart like yeah it's
just like zooming around it's very
aerodynamic back tank if you like action
if that is your main interest this movie
is certainly action packed to the best
moments of this movie excluding Channing
Tatum and you know what it totally
delivers on action thrills
all right let's move on to the reasons
not to see reason not to see number one
Flint so Flint plays one of those
remaining GI Joes you see the rock
survives this blast and to our left and
there's Flint at first a rebellious cool
[ __ ] who can do some awesome
flips yeah right about 20 minutes in
they scratch all that and he is one of
the most boring deers in the film yeah I
mean it just kind of becomes nondescript
after a while like they just nothing to
say about it yes he does give him the
same thing to do for a while and then
that's kind of that did he have
something to do in the movie besides be
a survivor of the GI Joes nothing you
think about that I don't remember nothin
now reason not to see number two doesn't
take advantage of Bruce Willis
all right yeah you all right the
cholesterol is relying so if you've seen
the trailer of the posters Bruce losses
in this phone if you find that exciting
don't be excited didn't because you know
what he's in it they they set him up
well because they're like he's the
reason why we're called jealous he's
dijo we have to assume that there's no
one we can trust there is one man
general call me Joe and you know what
they don't take advantage of general Joe
Colton and at first you're like oh this
is going to be a game-changer this is
going to be the cool cameo in the film
but the tournament's is just a small
supporting character in it like there's
nothing really special about him they
don't really need to really listen
besides just grabbing a few of his
weapons and stuff it's like they could
have you any way they could have used
like anyone else for the part that he
plays in this film it's just like they
cast Bruce was to make him a little bit
special but then they don't make the
character interesting it doesn't make
Bruce Willis interesting all of a sudden
you have John McClane / a bunch of other
crazy action people he's played like
give him something awesome to do and
he's a good actor too so I take
advantage of the role what's wrong with
you people ultimately like his is his
appearance in the film is amusing and
mildly exciting at most but it's not
like all Bruce Willis yes reason not to
see number three ridiculous plot points
the first half of this movie is a lot of
fun it's great action scenes it's a
total blast and the last half starts to
take some turns where you're like I
don't know so much about that you're
suspending my belief just a little bit
yes yeah like I don't have a problem
with suspension of disbelief for these
kinds of movies like you know you take
it on its own merits and I'm not here
for like complex character development
big big story arcs and stuff like that
but there is a point that this movie
firmly crosses where it's like this is a
bit too did ridiculous it's like when
your world domination plot involves
destroying
everything in the world one words left
it don t my fellow world leaders you're
looking at an advanced weapons system
capable of destroying each of your
country's 14 times over 15 in the case
of North Korea and all at the push of a
button
and the domination plot I'm not gonna
give it away but it's just silly like
when you see it yeah it's like whoa is
this how they interpret world leaders
like oh my god yeah how dumb do they
think world leaders are yeah I mean the
black kind of moves from a to be in such
a way where it's like I would just
because you know it's like certain
things happen that are really convenient
and it's like any amount of these things
wouldn't be a problem on their own for
me so much but when you stack all them
into this ridiculous silliness yeah it
does become distracting because I get
that like this film is mainly about
entertainment and their stuff in the
first half that's totally you know not
realistic but it's contained in this
world that's believable and then those
last half it's like I just don't no
reason not to see number four it drags
okay the first half like I said great
the last half starts to drag a little
bit that's when I felt the film star to
lose its sense of fun in then it started
seeming like the director was getting
unintentional laughs because he's tried
making a bad script have these moments
of seriousness when I felt like you
should have just kept it entertaining
throughout yeah I mean to me it didn't
really drag that much but that also
could just be because I was sometimes in
there trying to think back and put
together the stuff that got lost in
editing so yeah I might have been
distracted by either the ridiculousness
of whatever was going on or trying to
decipher certain certain editing choices
all right now let's move on to the split
decisions the one split decision
somewhat decisions lady j okay so lady j
is this hot girl that is part of the GI
Joe team one of the survivors and she's
hot but she is hot that is all I thought
she was capable of doing was being hot I
thought she was very boring to watch see
I didn't get bored watching her I
actually thought that she had some
personality and because she even in
those scenes worth just heard in Flint I
thought she brought the personality to
those scenes like I enjoyed watching her
and I enjoyed her you know quips and
one-liners and her plan off bruce willis
and stuff like that like
I liked her character I thought when her
Bruce Willis played off each other I
thought Bruce Willis was fun to watch I
didn't think she was fun to watch I
thought she was just a very bad actress
to be honest no well I enjoyed your
performance so and I'll still have sex
with you if you want all right so all
that stuff aside what's your consensus
then Ryan's consensus there are some fun
strong reasons to see GI joe retaliation
there are some fun strong reasons to see
GI joe retaliation the first half is a
total blast and you know what this movie
is mainly made for action junkies and it
totally delivers on the action Sherry's
consensus yeah there there are some
strong reasons to see GI joe retaliation
there are some strong reasons to see GI
joe retaliation for me this movie kind
of falls in the middle of these kinds of
movies I've seen big loud action movies
that I've liked a lot more and I've also
seen ones that have been tedious and I
liked a lot less so this one you know
it's alright alright guys thanks for
checking out our video if you want to
tell us your reasons to see and not to
see click in the comment box below and
if you want to hear my straight to the
point review of GI Joe retaliation if
you want to know what the differences
just hear the title it's straight to the
point of GI Joe retaliation click on the
link right here and if you want to see
more episodes of reasons to see click
the link right here alright guys if you
want to get updated every time a new
reviews out go ahead and subscribe
subscribe peeps subscript 0 porfavor
senorita I'm assuming that we mainly
have a fan gmail oh man why yeah yeah
it's good to say yeah I think I believe
that was the demographic for GI Joe
retaliation is just latinas latinas yeah
specifically old Latinas
you